Hey guys,
Welcome back to
the second part of the series, where we talk about
biblical financial principles every man must know.
In a previous video, we talked
about never creating debt.
Never spending money you don't
have on things you don't need.
Then we talked about investing.
And then we talked about creating
a budget every month.
Now, we're going to talk
about a total of eight things when it
comes to biblical financial principles.
And number five is saving money.
Specifically, saving money for the unknown future.
[Proverbs 21:20]
It is very important to save money
for the future because you never
know what the future will hold, right?
But also it is important to save money
for anything - unexpectedly - that can happen
at any time and then you're not ready for it.
You can do this by just putting aside
a portion of your income each month
into a savings account or an emergency fund.
Look, you never expect a flat tire but it happens.
In the same way you never expect your
water heater to burst, but it happens.
And those who do not plan for the
future, they're just planning to fail.
Unexpected things will happen.
And if you're not ready for it - your
whole family - you - you'll be in trouble.
So, all you got to do is save your money
for those, let's call it those flat tire days.
So that when it happens, you know you have some
money tucked away and it will solve the problem.
And then you will still have bread on the table.
[Proverbs 21:20]
You know, there are always
those who are gluttonous.
They are greedy for money.
And when they have money,
they just want to spend it.
They just want to live for the now
instead of thinking for the future.
Preparing for the future.
There are many people out
there who think like this...
Man, I still have one hundred dollars left.
Hmmm. What am I going to spend this on?
Instead of thinking man, I still
have one hundred dollars left,
let me save this for the future in case I need it.
Those who spend it recklessly find themselves in
need of money time and time again and they even
get angry when people do not want to help them.
Even when they ask their family.
If you have a family member or a friend
like this, then you should not help them
because you're actually helping them to stay
in that position and never learn their lesson.
They're thinking, man, I have money.
I'm just going to spend it.
And then when I come to that point where
they don't have money, oh I'm gonna ask
John, I'm gonna ask Susan.
They will always help me.
And then I keep on doing that.
They stay in that comfort zone.
You will help them more if
you don't give them money.
Because then they will learn.
Man, it's my own actions that
brought me into this position.
Now I'm in trouble so I'm
not going to do this again.
We have an Afrikaans saying...
If this is you and you just spend money without
thinking about it, then you need to know that
there's always consequences.
You will reap what you sow.
If you sow not thinking, just spending all the
time, what do you think is going to happen?
You're going to have trouble.
You will reap what you sow.
But there's good news.
The good news is that you can
change and that you can change today.
Let's move on to the next one.
Avoid get rich quick schemes.
[Proverbs 13:11]
God's blessing will be upon you if you
work hard for the bread on the table.
For your money.
If you walk within His will, what
He wants you to do, but not if you want to join
get rich quick schemes and do you want to just try
some shortcuts to get ahead - even bribing people
in business - His blessing will not be upon you.
Also, if you do the lottery or you
go gambling, Isaiah 65:11-12 says...
Trying to get rich quick often leads to financial
ruin because you're doing that ... you're walking
in your own will.
Your own desire.
Fleshly desires.
You're not walking in God's will.
We need to work hard for
the money that we receive.
You need to earn it and then you can
focus on making wise financial decisions
over time, like investing in stable
long-term investment opportunities.
If you work hard for your money, if you walk
within God's will and do what He wants you
to do with your life, He will bless you.
You don't want to make the wrong decisions
and not have God's blessing on your life.
That's the worst thing that can happen to you.
Choose your friends wisely.
Now, you might think Daniel,
what does this have to do with
biblical financial principles?
Well, everything.
Dave Ramsey also talks about it.
He's very wise and also well known talking
about biblical financial principles.
And I watched some of his videos,
especially when I was younger.
And it's interesting just to
hear what he says about this.
But your friends will influence you and
that includes the way you handle your money.
[Proverbs 27:17]
[1 Corinthians 15:33]
Do not be deceived.
Bad company ruins good morals.
You see, children learn the
habits of their parents.
They start to mimic you, and you -
when you look - you just say, oh man,
he's doing the same thing that I've been doing.
And I didn't even notice that he learned this.
I didn't even teach it to him because
they watch you carefully and it's
the same thing when they go to school.
They pick up things from their friends.
Wrong habits at times when they come home and
you realize, man, this is something different.
I didn't teach.
Where did you learn this?
And you start that conversation and
when we grow up nothing changes.
Truth is truth, right?
So it doesn't change.
We still pick up things from
the people we mingle with.
From our friends, especially who you spend most of
your time with, and this truth will never change.
Bad friends will make you worse and
good friends will make you better.
Inspiring you to improve yourself.
If you hang around with friends who
make good business decisions - who plan
ahead and who educate themselves with good
books - you will learn from them.
And want to do the same.
And this will influence the way you handle money.
Let's move on to the next one, and the last one.
Trust in and honor God with your finances.
Ultimately, our financial security and
our ultimate well-being comes
from God in the first place.
And it continues that way especially for us as
reborn Christians as we grow spiritually in Him.
Everything we do, we do through the Spirit.
And that includes the way you handle your money.
[Proverbs 3:5]
By trusting God and following
His principles, that is how you
can have true financial peace and security.
And you will be a better businessman with God.
Proverbs 3 verse 9-10 says...
Let me ask you a question.
Do you honor God with your money?
In this temporary world, you should
use your finances to honor God.
And use it to further His kingdom.
Because when you die and you stand before Him,
what will He say to you?
What have you done with
the money that I've given you?
You see, by giving generously you
can take part in God's work while you are still
here on this earth and also enjoy His blessings.
[2 Corinthians 9:6-7]
meaning the Holy Spirit needs to lead you.
I can tell you this with confidence - if
you prove that you can be trusted with
money then God might bless you more
financially because He knows He can
trust you to use it responsibly and make
wise decisions to use it for His kingdom.
Or do you think God will just bless you with
money to spend it on your own fleshly desires?
That you want to live in luxury for
just this short temporary world?
To live in pleasure only for yourself?
And you know this is exactly why He does not
bless certain people with money when they ask Him.
Because He knows this is what they will do.
[James 4:3]
So God will bless you
financially if it is His will.
And if He knows that He can trust you.
And first, when He does bless you,
you need to have financial security yourself
first before you can help other people.
[Proverbs 14:21]
So you need to help the poor but you need
to be wise in how you do that because
the old saying of if you just buy a poor man
a fish, he'll expect you to do that always.
But if you buy him the equipment to catch
fish himself, you'll feed him forever, right?
Not only do you need to help the poor,
you also need to help the kingdom of God.
What does that mean?
You can support
preachers - missionaries - and also ministries.
Even online ministries like DLM.
People who rely on God to send
them the money, to share the
Gospel the way that He wants them to do it.
And God usually does that through his children.
Brothers and sisters in Christ, that He blesses
financially and expects them to help those who
do not have normal work hours.
You know, just Monday to Friday.
But all that they do is sharing the gospel.
That is their full-time jobs.
You know, when Israel did not
give back to God, He warned them.
God says in Malachi 3 verse 8:
And let me read this verse to
you again in the New Testament.
[2 Corinthians 9:6-7]
[2 Corinthians 9:12]
You know, I just want to say this.
Whatever church you are going to,
I grew up in a church.
I saw my dad working day and
night - people knocking - people phoning - and
then he has to preach in the sermons and after
the sermons work with people - psychological
stuff - help them to grow spiritually - and
they were things at their homes.
I mean, the whole week, day and night,
and I saw how much it costs to run
a church, to do all these things.
To put on the lights and then still people
complained about giving money to the church.
After all that work.
And listen carefully - you should
not give money to fake churches.
To churches of false teachers.
But you should help the true
church of God to do its work.
To save souls and to help people
grow spiritually in Christ.
You know, this is how the devil works.
People never complain about giving money
out when they go to see a movie or when they
go to see a show, you know, or a concert.
Yeah sure, here we go.
Let's go.
But they expect to go to the church
to get everything for free.
Life-changing sermons through
the power of the Holy Spirit.
And they are selfish.
They don't want to give anything to God.
Why?
That is your sinful fleshly heart.
Paul actually talked about this directly.
[1 Corinthians 9:3]
You see, this is not something
that just is happening right now.
This is something that was always there,
because humans, we always have our sinful
flesh even as Christians and money is one of
the things that brings most of the trouble
Christians experience, even in marriages.
[1 Corinthians 9:4-10]
Now he's been working towards the point
that he wants to make and here it comes.
[1 Corinthians 9:11-13]
Now, listen to this.
[1 Corinthians 9:14]
Do you understand this?
Even today there are
preachers out there - churches who want to
follow Jesus Christ- pure hearts who want
to share the Gospel through the Holy Spirit.
But they are struggling to just have food on
the table because the church is not willing
to obey God and help them financially.
So I want you to pray about the
church that you're going to.
Ask God - God, am I giving
enough? Or should I give less?
Maybe I should give a little bit less and
maybe give to these people or that people.
You know, you should pray about this
because the Holy Spirit should lead you.
There are some people who are angry, you
know, when the church talks about this and
so a lot of churches don't even preach about this.
They are content with food and clothing and they
just try to do the best that they can even though
they're struggling to keep bread on the table.
That's what I saw growing up with my father.
Now on that note, I just want to thank you for
those of you who partnered with me and my team,
who are helping us financially to keep on
sharing the Gospel in the way that we do.
We would not have been able
to do this without your help.
So thank you.
There are some of you that want
to partner with us monthly.
All the information is in the
video description down below.
We would love to expand our team to share
the gospel even more effectively with
all nations and all people.
But, if God is not leading
you to help us, then don't do it.
You need to pray about this first.
Maybe He wants you to help someone else.
Another church, another missionary.
I don't know.
You need to pray about this.
So, how else can you honor God with your finances?
By taking care of your own family.
If your relatives are struggling, you need to
help them, especially if you know that they
are doing their best, working really hard,
making wise decisions and they're still
struggling because they might be praying to God
to help them and God is actually blessing you.
And it's a test for you.
They want you to help them so don't keep
that money selfishly, just spending it on your
own desires while those around you are struggling.
[1 Timothy 5:8]
Now, if your attitude towards money
is right, if you want to honor God financially,
use the money that He gives you responsibly.
Then God will bless you with your finances
and you always need to remember this:
[Acts 20:35]
Start today and put these biblical principles of
how to deal with money - with your finances - put
it into practice starting today.
And rely on Him for provision.
If you deal with money the right way -
responsibly using it for God's kingdom - for
your family - using it wisely - planning for the
future - all these principles that we discussed in
these two videos - then God will be with you.
And He will help you.
He will guide you and you can
just move forward with Him.
Now, always remember, that life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Bye guys.